this video brought to you by the fine
folks at team locks key blocks is an
affordable subscription-based service
that delivers custom t-shirts straight
to your doorstep with licensed art from
Marvel DC Disney Star Wars Naruto Game
of Thrones Breaking Bad and a whole lot
more you can support my channel today
and get 10% off your first order with a
special promo code Godzilla tbx
go get some cool shirts boys and girls
it's a la Beach Wounded Knee work strif
the first day on the psalm and only now
or an automatic fire into a human wall
do I feel something like peace also I
was Frankenstein one time thanks to the
TV industry destroying power of good old
Netflix Punisher is now relevant in the
mainstream again and this time it's not
for another terrible tragedy that
everyone will send thoughts and prayers
to thoughts and prayers go out to those
in the television industry losing their
jobs because of YouTube and Netflix
though hope none of you decide to take
up vigilantism and attempt to wipe out
all of the online entertainers though
because that would though it would like
really slow down my production schedule
pretty significantly what was I talking
about Oh The Punisher well much like
deadpool and spiderman i've spent a lot
of time reading punisher comics from all
over the place and he's probably in my
top 5 favorite Marvel characters so
getting to review this one is a treat
for a fan of the books special thanks to
the wonderful Dane Amy OTT for
requesting this review after donating to
the highest patreon tier when I set up
my patreon I put that last reward tier
in there as a joke but someone was
actually generous and crazy enough to go
for it he thankfully gave me an excuse
to review this appreciate a buddy hope I
do you proud oh man I hope no one finds
that guy makes a vlog about him relevant
alright let's get into it
do you like violence do you like
unrepentant mass disposal of criminals
with a variety of long range anti living
equipment then this game is for you this
game ranks up with some of the most
brutal I've ever played I have to hear
people compare it to manhunt from the
developers of Saints Row volition put
this together shortly after the Thomas
Jane movie was released in 2004 it's
actually pretty clear how much of the
Saints Row series was based on this game
mechanically with a similar engine very
similar mechanics and dare I say even
some reused animations
heck I think I've seen some of these
getting recycled all the way up in Hill
central for got their money's worth they
built that to have some mileage but
unlike Saints Row where you are the
criminals you're an exterminator for
criminals and instead of getting paid
you just do this out of the kindness of
your cold black Frank Castle heart ah
this game doesn't have the seductive
Marvel voice lady the gameplay is pretty
ahead of its time I think you can dive
roll take cover
ask questions in a forceful manner long
distance on live extreme acupuncture and
cuddle with crime to avoid getting
turned into Swiss cheese if you didn't
think of a thing Punisher does in the
comics you can pretty much do it here
plus a few extra things Punisher doesn't
do in the comics like perform laser eye
surgery or feed animals in the forest
do your best Isaac Clark impression good
god we're one step away from being the
manga Punisher
some of these start to feel really
mean-spirited and horrible it's awesome
although ESRB had to get all
uncomfortable with it made you lose
points if you question a baddie and then
do exactly what punisher would do then
they added this black and white filter
and have the camera angles change so
it's not quite as disturbing if you get
the pc version all of these mini
sequences can be totally uncensored
though so you can appreciate the game
how is intended to be you sicko oh dude
the most expensive upgrade basically
gives you splatterhouse powers I'm gonna
save up for that one you can also
question guys that will occasionally
give you PTSD flashbacks to Nam
it reminds me of another semi-related
thing I've been meaning to talk about in
a video I hope you don't mind if I
sidetrack for a moment you know who else
went to Nam spider-man one time but it
was an else world story by James Tuco
that was proposed to Marvel and they
never made it the arc for this book
looks amazing and the premise is so out
there I highly recommend you take a look
at some of the samples of the art and
story that I put in the description this
is one of those weird premises like
spider-man noir that's so crazy it has
to work can someone get on making a
petition to get this restarted I'll
personally back the movement I'd read
the hell out of this story if I was
Charlie and I saw this guy out in the
fields doing this to one of my tanks I'd
March my ass back into the bug infested
forest so hard was it talking about oh
yeah
why do all of these shield agents sound
like various Deadpool voice actors fury
said you might be here did he say to
stay out of my way no my orders are to
hold here there should be a SHIELD agent
ahead just be sure to shoot them not us
in general I think the gameplay feels
pretty smooth and responsive you can
hold two instruments of retribution at
once but it's more than enough to handle
a roomful of enemies the early missions
have you feeling so overpowered that you
want to take on the whole world and as
we know the Punisher is one of the two
people who can do that geez dual
wielding boomsticks requires a ton of
upper-body strength
Frank's been doing his push-ups after
you've kind of flown through the first
few levels it starts to throw you a
curveball with more opponents and less
resources to work with while most games
would encourage you to get stealthy at
this point stealth isn't really a factor
here the sneaked mechanic only really
works when there's one guy around and
everywhere else is so populated that
you're spotted the second you walk into
a door so what's the solution then well
then just uh go louder and harder I
guess subtlety is for the weak I think
that's really the only complaint I have
with this game play is that stealth and
subterfuge isn't really an option it's
always this really loud persistent
hectic plethora of pain and yelling and
swirlies you don't often get a moment to
just chill out and plan ahead but that's
one of the things I like most about
Punisher he's always planning ahead he
has the ability to play it cool and
agent 47 his way through bad situations
I guess in a broader sense some variety
would have been nice in the gameplay
plus the boss fights with the exception
of that transsexual cyborg in the
striped shirt are pretty than
I think they kind of cheaped out on most
of the bosses they're pretty uncreated
it usually just boils down to a normal
enemy type that's tougher than average
or one that can only be taken down via
better marksmanship bullseye has a
literal target on his head this game
does what it does extremely well but
that's all it does there's very minimal
exploration and if you play it all in
one sitting I'm sure would lose a lot of
its steam before the end thankfully
though I played this over the course of
a week or two with a lot of room in
between so the charm didn't wear off as
quickly I think that's the preferred
method of enjoying it anyway as for
punisher stuff for fans it's got
everything you could want it's written
by Garth Ennis who did some of the
legendarily good Punisher comics and
this game is chock-full of references
and easter eggs for his books
I think the collectibles offer a lot of
charm with these goofy newspaper
clippings with totally nonsensical
visual aids that clearly they didn't
think too hard about like what is this
one that's a plane flying away from a
giant ball of light after a mission
where he sinks a freighter but later in
the game this exact visual happens in
the newspaper clipping has a totally
different comic panel on it so what is
this image supposed to even be a less
dumb example of collectibles paying
tribute to the finisher is the game's
armory where Frank has a fun factor
tidbit about every single piece of
equipment compact and convenient fires
the same ammo
five caliber semi-automatic which saves
even more space this reminds me a lot of
this series from the 90s called Punisher
the armory which has several issues if
nothing but Shane Byrne Falls Arsenal
pages and pages of it with no story just
him giving personal accounts and
opinions on each item and his own uses
for them kind of experimental for a
comic but if you're interested in
learning more about that kind of stuff I
found it very educational not a bad read
and it's cool to see something so
obscure getting a homage in this game
it's one of the more subtle but
definitely most appreciated pieces of
fanservice and of course what comic book
game is complete without alternate
costumes there's plenty of cheats to
dress up as various different punish
man's outfits though unfortunately
they're only available to wear during
two missions and only on the PC version
of the game da man if this game came out
a few years later they could have used
his Captain America costume period or
his other Captain America costume
variant because there's two of them for
some reason it sucks that the console
players can't get any costumes I really
like his classic look with the white
gloves and boots
there's also Garth Ennis his trademark
dark sense of humor with a lot of
horrible stuff interspersed with
criminals being silly and incompetent
and ironically I think he eased off of
his usual dark and grim take on the
Punisher himself Punisher still feels
like the character we all loved but he's
allowed to crack a witty joke every now
and then and it really sells the tone of
the story and makes you root for him
[Music]
that's not to say Garth Ennis typically
writes him as a hard-ass all the time
but I feel like his funnier comments are
spaced out and less frequent in stories
like Punisher Max and of course Thomas
Jane is a really great voice actor for
Punisher I may not like the movie he was
in but damn does his voice sound perfect
the story itself is fantastic with just
enough variety and intrigue to keep you
going and more villains than you can
shake a tramatic backstory at we start
with father of the Year finally getting
taken in by the cops and being
interrogated by two characters familiar
to anyone who's read Marvel Knights
Punisher I like this one sofe is like
the biggest loser in the Marvel Universe
he gets promoted to the police
commissioner and then loses a job after
a week plus a whole bunch other stuff
also he's the Punishers informant and
sort of bumbling sidekick these two ask
him how exactly everything got to this
point and he strolls back through memory
lane and recalls his casual brushes with
ultraviolence and extreme persuasion
something I love about The Punisher is
the way he treats military hardware so
casually in operation with dozens of
casualties property damage and severe
injuries is like a day at work like
building a deck in the backyard
like building a deck we learned through
the course of the game how no family guy
got to this point
walking through crime boss is like Manu
Chi kingpin general creep cough and he
even fights some Yakuza of course all
these groups are being orchestrated
against pun pun by an unseen figure whom
I won't spoil and the final mission has
us going after that mystery villain
without saying who it is I kind of
dislike the way the game tries to relate
itself back to the 2004 movies bad plot
like it turns a pretty cool comic
villain into a recurring character from
that film and it makes them way less
interesting also the final boss is
really clunky and just lacks that same
enthusiasm and pacing of everything else
in the game before it it's kind of a
slog to beat that one and I think they
could have done something less lame with
what they had to work with someone's
ripping me off how do i defuse your
bombs Oh like I haven't heard that
before
mm anyway there's a huge variety of
locations for gameplay in a really
decent number of them or references or
callback to awesome discipline or
storylines from Garth Ennis mostly his
work on the 6-1-6 Punisher I also love
the amount of Marvel Universe cameos and
references despite how much Garth
despises them he bit the bullet and let
characters like Black Widow Matt Murdock
Nick Fury and Iron Man all have a place
in this story and it's much appreciated
for the people who don't want to write
60 issue comics about how much they hate
the concept of superheroes the boys is
still good though oh hey Black Widow you
want to start an anime film with me I'm
just mad that there wasn't a mission
about destroying Wolverines face and
gonads and parking a steamroller on him
while his screams become muffled and his
limbs twitch brutality yeah he's okay
I'll walk it off he's a tough guy now
that I think about it Russian accent
Natasha and Papa patch man look and
sound a lot like how they do in Ultimate
Alliance
maybe this is canon to that game
universe and if that's true then that
would also mean
hey Frank Castle how's it goin man got
any plans for the weekend I was gonna
take my not wife and three non-canon
daughters out for a picnic in Central
Park
I sure hope nothing bad happens while
we're there
Wow cool that was pretty impressive but
anyway you want to see if you could come
along with us come on it'll be fun you
could drop the whole stoic one-man army
lives in a van and cuddles a shotgun
tonight act for an afternoon if you want
you could even bring the wife and KITT
okay nice chatting with you have a nice
evening bye alright I played the entire
game without getting a single upgrade so
I could do this I hope it's worth the
penny-pinching wait that's it are you
serious sometimes I'd like to get my
hands on God you like the 12th episode
of the Netflix show this game feels like
you're playing that it's got all kinds
of neat little tributes and nods for
longtime Punisher fans and it really
feels like a lot of love for the
character was baked into every head
burst and window toss I'm really lucky
to have found a playable copy of it and
I think every fan of the character
should add it to their collection it's a
rollicking good time and you'll only
feel slightly awful for enjoying it so
much check it out
15 out of 10 basically Call of Duty
[Music]
[Music]